welcome to the David Pakman show we are
back from summer vacation and so much to
talk about so much happened while we
were gone and I'm going to talk about a
lot of it today hurricane Harvey of
course has been devastating southern
Texas over the last several days waters
are actually still rising in many areas
of Texas this is the strongest hurricane
on US land since 2004 in terms of wind
the storm formed a week and a half ago a
near Barbados it gained hurricane status
on Thursday in the Gulf of Mexico Harvey
first made landfall Friday night near
Corpus Christi Texas as a category 4
hurricane and during its peak of
intensity it had winds as high as 130
miles per hour and since we've seen
multiple isolated tornadoes catastrophic
flooding especially in the Houston area
five confirmed deaths as of this morning
and hopefully that number will not have
gone up by the time you hear or see this
program but it might Texas governor Greg
Abbott has mobilized about 3,000
National Guard members about 30,000
people are expected to end up in
shelters nearly half a million expected
to need some degree of disaster
assistance and 13 million people in
total under flood watches and warnings
throughout this entire horrific storm
and Harvey has now been downgraded to a
tropical storm rain and flooding
expected to continue for several days
the center of the storm is heading
towards northwestern Texas and parts of
the Houston area are projected to reach
50 inches of rain by Wednesday Friday
night again a hundred and thirty mile an
hour winds devastating the coast of
Texas just sort of pushing around huge
pieces of equipment like entire tractor
trailers like they weigh almost nothing
and many of us in the lead-up to the
hurricane were thinking back to that
disastrous George W Bush administration
response to Hurricane Katrina and Donald
Trump seems to have sort of sunk even
lower
did George W Bush Trump took to Twitter
during the lead-up to and even during
the throes of this hurricane including a
tweet bragging about pardoning racist
Arizona sheriff Joe Arpaio who was
convicted of committing human rights
abuses will talk in more detail about
that pardoned later but Donald Trump
again when you've got a huge portion of
the country preparing for what was at
that point clearly going to be a
devastating storm he goes to Twitter and
he says I'm pleased to inform you that I
have just granted a full pardon
capitalising pardon why we don't know
- 85 year-old American patriot Sheriff
Joe Arpaio he kept America Arizona safe
Trump also choosing Friday night as the
right time to announce his new directive
to the Defense Department to conduct a
study on transgender people in the
military another issue that's been part
of the totally pointless gong show of
so-called governance under Donald Trump
and at first I thought oh it's
insensitive timing talking about our
piyo and the Department of Defense
transgender thing and then I realize no
this was probably deliberate the White
House choosing to talk about these
issues at this time so that it would
hopefully be buried by news about
hurricane Harvey and then Donald Trump
spent the rest of the weekend continuing
to show Americans just how focused he
was on hurricane Harvey Sunday morning
in the midst of the disaster in Texas
Trump posts a tweet promoting his
friend's new book this was written by
Milwaukee's controversial Sheriff David
Clarke who's called Planned Parenthood
genocidal and is called black people
lazy and morally corrupt Donald Trump
goes to Twitter and says a great book by
a great guy highly recommended and you
see there it is a link to David Clarke
Jr's book a horrible book by the way
people are telling me and reading
reading very very important I'm one of
the best people at reading but people
say trust me folks one of the best books
an hour and a half later he gets back on
Twitter and starts bragging about how he
won the state of Missouri during the
election and
criticize Connecticut Senator Chris
Murphy for opposing his tax cuts
tweeting again floodwaters continuing to
rise Trump goes to Twitter I will also
be going to a wonderful state Missouri
that I won by a lot in 2016 16 Democrats
cm meaning Chris Murphy is opposed to
big big tax cuts Republican will win s
Murphy responded by tweeting my god at
this exact moment people are dying in
the worst natural disaster of his
presidency and instead of leading he's
attacking Democrats and then 30 minutes
later Donald Trump starts tweeting about
how Mexico is going to pay for the wall
bringing that nonsense back to life
tweeting with Mexico being one of the
highest crime nations in the world we
must have the wall Mexico will pay for
it through reimbursement slash other why
do I feel that reimbursement slash other
is a category that plays into the
potential tax fraud that Donald Trump
has committed maybe will someday find
out about that and of course at this
point multiple people had been confirmed
dead by the hurricane Trump still had
not mentioned their deaths five minutes
later he starts complaining about trade
negotiations with Mexico and Canada
quote we are in the NAFTA worst trade
deal ever made renegotiation process
with Mexico and Canada both being very
difficult may have to terminate the
tweets Donald Trump did ultimately send
about the hurricane are mostly patting
himself on the back talking about the
great response that the White House
coordinated whatever and here's the sick
irony or the sick reality of it
President Obama passed a regulation in
2015 to make our infrastructure more
flood proof remember infrastructure was
going to be a big part of trumps
administration two weeks ago Trump
reversed that regulation before it even
took effect it would have required new
bridges roads other structures to be
built on safer ground that's susceptible
to flooding during hurricanes exactly in
this type of scenario hurricane Harvey
the first major domestic natural
disaster of Trump's presidency and like
the first everything of trumps
presidency
an unmitigated disaster it is times like
these when presidents are supposed to
bring the country together so show of
support and compassion for victims of
the disaster help give the country some
kind of sense of hope in a tumultuous
time
these are gimmies and Trump just can't
do it tweeting about David Clarke's book
and Chris Murphy and tax cuts and build
the wall and whatever he's handled it
exactly the way we would expect him to
using the hurricane coverage to try to
announce controversial White House
decisions hopefully hoping that they'll
be overlooked and spending the weekend
insulting Mexico and starting Twitter
drama with Democrats we remember
Hurricane Katrina because it was a sort
of turning point for george w bush's
presidency widespread criticism of the
bush administration for their handling
of katrina
and then Bush's approval rating hit an
unprecedented low Trump has had
unprecedented low after low throughout
his first six seven months in office
what will we see next just absolutely
and totally pathetic handling of this by
President Donald Trump the video you
just finished watching was made possible
by you through the membership program
you can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership